hey what's up my name's samuel lee and
i'm amanda and this is the samuel and
amanda show where we talk about money
marriage and life and this week what are
we going to be talking about we're going
to be talking about tenants
and also we're going to be responding
and reacting to unhappy tenants on tick
tock and looking at their point of view
because we often like you know we pull
our hair out with tenants i mean
honestly especially in our hmo
properties if you have like a young
professional moving in they might say
things like that they'll bring you up
and they'll say the um the light in my
room isn't working and you're like oh
that's really odd yeah you send the
electrician out and the electrician
calls up and says it's because the ball
ran out
i kind of think happens all the time so
we see things from the
landlord's
perspective uh however we're going to be
looking at tick tock videos of tenants
moaning some of them are quite funny
mandy's not
i've checked the videos out some of them
were really funny some of them i
actually agree with the tenant other
times i agree with the landlord uh if
you're a landlord or if you're a tenant
comment below let me know are you a
landlord or are you a tenant or like me
and amanda are you both because we
actually are lieutenant as well yes we
are we rent this house that we that we
live in so um all right we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna react some of
the videos however please do like the
video if you enjoy these um videos that
mean amanda let us know by liking the
video we had loads of likes last week i
know you guys really showed us the love
last week in fact the last week last
week's video that me and amanda did it
was our most popular samanda show video
that we've ever done so we're going to
respond to some of these videos so we'll
do it let's start with this one this one
i thought this one was my favorite this
one i thought was really funny okay i'm
just checking in to see how you're
getting on with the flat
oh it's infested with rats
oh
dear but i don't
i don't really see how that's a me
problem that kind of sounds more like a
you problem i mean aren't you the one
living there
anyway while i've got you on the phone i
need to know what you're going to be
doing at the end of the 12-month
tennessee i know we're only one weekend
but this is my livelihood the idea of
that house that flat being empty for
more than a day turns my stomach
if you're not going to want to take it
let me know because i need to do
viewings on the flat there's going to be
a lot of viewings because no one's going
to want to take it because no one's just
stupid as you
anyway yeah just let me know all right
bye
[Music]
what was the caption on that what was
the caption that was that was um an
impression of his landlord
that was hilarious the landlord sounds
like
he literally just does that like that's
his thing like he's just literally just
down breathing down the tenants back all
the time because he clearly hasn't got
anything
oh
that's brilliant um come a bit closer
we've um what do you think what do you
think of the girl what do you think of
this i just thought it was just a funny
impression i'd love to see what the
landlord would actually be like well
probably just like that
so you're weak as well
how long are you going
i know whoa chill out
after the 12 months
yeah i think you know what um
i think that we've with tenants number
one in terms of what they're going to do
yeah the reason someone's renting is
because they want flexibility so
genuinely the tenant often doesn't know
what they're going to be doing
so they would know that like in a year's
time it's like really whoever his
landlord is is completely unreasonable
and with the rats and the rats things
well um okay whose job is it to get rid
of rats landlords or tenants usually
pests i believe are the land
thing to sort oh really yeah i think so
i'm sure when it's like because when
it's been like
i don't know i don't know if it's
different when it's hmos oh
yeah yeah
definitely i always feel like we just
sort it out but when it's just like a
normal bicep me personally for our
tenants i have always sorted it out just
because i'm just thinking i think
technically they should just contact the
council and then that's how they usually
do it i think we're probably too nice
because in our ex in our experience with
our with our tenants if a tenant
contacted us with a pest problem as
landlords we would sort it yeah we have
had people messages haven't win so
they've got like a wasp nest in the
garden or whatever yeah and we've
stepped in and sorted it
but then as tenants we never would call
the landlord yeah yeah we just sorted
ourselves if we're living in the house
then we just yeah
and i think it might also depend on the
size of the house and the circumstances
um yeah but generally speaking it's good
to just keep the tenants sweet and keep
them on side and how much i think costs
like 35 pounds to get someone to go out
and move the watch for nestle oh yeah
it's not really worth arguing about all
right next this one is um this one's
funny as well
i just got a call from my landlord and
he said hello is this max i said yes it
is and he said hi well you don't know
this but when you started renting the
property we'd actually brought the rent
down because of corvid and he said so
we're gonna have to bring it back up
again
i said no
and he said yeah so it's to be an extra
200 pounds a month i said no
i said was that in my contract and he
said no you see it wasn't so i said well
guess bloody what then
no
and he said oh well um i'll have to go
away and then ring some people up and
then i'll let you know if they make the
final decision as to whether you have to
pay i said listen
you clearly don't know who i am
i once verbally wrestled
with my landlord for a good five to six
months over a 45 pound fine that i
shouldn't have paid
you can get to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he
what do is
think i think the landlord is just
ridiculous oh i think that looks
ridiculous as well
actually that seems just so ridiculous
like
200 pounds as well i mean come on
200 pounds
the thing is it all depends on the other
side of the story is is he in contract
or not that's the question well i guess
he says he's they're not he says is it
in my contract he said no no no what i'm
saying is like let's say you move into a
house and you sign a six-month ast
contract yeah if the six-month buyer's
team contract then ends and you're
rolling you're now on it yeah and then
you want to put the right i guess that's
different then that's fine yeah it does
sound like an offer it sounds like he's
just trying to change the goal first the
landlord yeah also all of a sudden just
because he just thinks i can get a bit
more rent now also if you put the rent
up generally speaking i mean 200 pounds
i don't know how much weight he's paying
but no that seems
extortionate that's a lot of rent to put
up right so and he's he sounds like a
funny guy he's funny
i love his personality he seems really
funny all right all right next next
i thought paying rent was like my
subscription fee that everything in my
apartment will be taken care of and now
i just learned i have to buy my own
light bulbs and install them myself
where am i supposed to get a fluorescent
light bulb
where do they sell those
uh they sell them in shops i'm not with
him disagree i don't know if he's joking
but even if he's joking i'm sure that
there's some truth in it yeah that's
kind of just nah i mean
it depends on the property you're
renting i guess if you're renting like a
professional high-end hmo property
but yeah he's the kind of tenant that
you just don't want yeah i know someone
who's just he's entitled doesn't he just
expecting that just because he's paying
your rent that you have to do everything
include wiping his bum yeah exactly and
i think a lot of tenants that move out
for the first time one of the things
that we often avoid is a tenant who's
moving out of their family home for the
first time so maybe like a 22 year old
who's lived at home their entire life
and it's their first time moving into a
house they tend to be the worst kind of
tenants because they used to sometimes
they're used to their moms doing
everything for them cooking cleaning
they leave mess the other tenants don't
like them uh they ring up because
there's no toilet paper in the property
you know the bin liners
that kind of stuff so those are the
worst kind of tenants because when you
move into a hmo you kind of it's nice
when they appreciate the fact that
there's been liners already in the house
yes it's nice but then to them
yeah yeah really annoying yeah the best
i feel like tenants of the tenants that
are kind of a bit more older mature
have really good jobs and literally the
the house is their home but it's like
their base they go to work come home
yeah tenants in their 30s as opposed to
their 20s do tend to be better yeah of
course that's not always the case
it sounds like i've been very
stereotypical all right last one last
one let us know what you think about
these videos as well do you agree with
us what do you think about what they're
saying all right last one let's see what
this is
i'm really angry but i'm trying so hard
to be calm
my previous tenancy agency are trying to
charge me for an end of tenancy clean
which by the way is illegal in the uk
now but they're claiming it's because i
left it in a terrible state compared to
when i got it bearing in mind when i got
that flat it was filthy i have emails
saying this is disgusting you need to
pay me for cleaning they said they don't
do cleaning um
the carpets were covered in feces and
urine anyway
i have picture evidence of that and
picture evidence of my flat being clean
when i left um but they're saying that
you know they had to get cleaner in so i
asked them to send proof of invoice
and the invoice is made up the company
doesn't exist um and the photo
evidence are just photos of everything
else but what they're saying needed
cleaning and bearing in mind the things
they said did need cleaning
uh what was there when i moved in and
again i have photo evidence of that that
they're trying to charge me and the
company doesn't exist
oh they sound awful the letting agent
yeah and you know what i also think as
well i think she
i don't know why i have a feeling that
she's probably a really good tenant yeah
she moved into this property and it
apparently was an estate that's that's
dreadful yeah who knows the
circumstances and why that was
but then the fact that i really hate it
and i've had this done we've had this
when you leave the property immaculate
but then the landlord tries to find i
know
it's almost like the landlord doesn't
want to give you a deposit back just
because and then they're like i mean i'm
russell my brother had a situation
whereby he was renting a property and he
asked the landlord permission if he
could um
do do a bit of noise turf grass yeah put
some turf down at the back make it make
the garden nice also put a few slabs
down because the garden previously by
the way was dreadful it was just like
overgrown not nice and russell's asked
to land look at permission to do this
this this and the landlord was like yeah
it's absolutely fine and then when
russell and anna moved out the landlord
said oh um i didn't want those slabs
down and he tried to charge
russell to move the slabs and he never
the landlord never really moved the
slabs he was just i think you're just
trying to hold some money back just to
get some questions
just get landlords just give your
tenants that didn't want it back
the purpose of a deposit is to stop them
trashing the place i mean i'm sure we as
well like we we left oh what was it now
it was the barn when we moved out
what happened the bath had um there was
like a little crack on the
back panel and it had always been there
when we moved in but then when we moved
out suddenly the landlord was all trying
like he was picking little little things
that usually anyway would be maybe wear
and tear but we haven't caused the
damage and it was just like why are you
doing this and i'm sure we left
something like a spoon on the kitchen
and he tried to charge us like 10 pounds
to move the spoon or something it was
just the actual drawers
i think i think from a tech if i'm
advising a tenant what i'll say is when
you move into a property make sure that
when the inventory is done because there
should always be an inventory so when
you move into a property or when you
move somebody into your property um it's
just pictures and a description of
exactly what the property is like
if you're a tenant just make sure that
you check the inventory check it's right
check it's fair look around the property
yourself and if you see any um you know
crack marks on the doors marks on the
walls cracks in the sinks or anything
like that at all
make the agent or the landlord put it in
the inventory and if you're a landlord
just don't be a greedy jerk you just
don't need to be if it's quite obvious
when a tenant is i mean there was there
was a time i remember once when we
accidentally left
an iron mark in the carpet and we just
said we owned up to it we said oh we
actually unfortunately
now you know that's fine yeah you're
going to have to of course pay for that
to be rectified um but generally
speaking if you've got a tenant if they
move out you can tell if the property is
left yeah you can tell that they've been
looking after it and then some things
have just happened there's just
someone's been living in the house but
yeah i always make sure that check the
inventory i think usually have like
seven days to respond with additional
things but even if i notice something
after that time period i literally just
take a photo send it to the agent and
make them confirm that they've received
it and then that way at the end of the
tenancy then they can just you know and
also if the landlord is complaining
about something as a tenant you should
say look if you're upset with it let me
come and fix it let me come and um and
then they'll normally say i don't bother
because yeah
because they're not even going to use
that money to fix it they're just doing
it to just cause you trouble for you
know just yeah just because the landlord
resents giving
back which is absolutely ridiculous
another thing as well with tenants and
landlords is putting up the rent if
you've got a tenant that's good and
that's been there years
uh we often have this where because
rents have boomed the last couple of
years when it's gone like really high my
advice is to be reasonable is don't
don't think you either have to just keep
the rent the same or you have to put it
right up and have it at the going rent
you can kind of compromise so we had
some tenants that were paying rent of
about 550 pounds
now the going rent is about 750 but
we've met in the middle and we've said
look um
the rents are actually about 750 now
you're paying 550. you're a really nice
family and and we want you to stay in
the property however we are gonna have
to put the rent up a little bit to 650.
i hope that's okay and they were fine
with that weren't they and they were
like thank you so much they're not going
to move out because
if they move out they're gonna have to
pay 750 but at the same time you're i
think i think it's about being fair and
about being reasonable and remembering
that your tenants are your customers and
if you didn't have tenants then you
actually would we wouldn't have a
passive income if we didn't have tenants
so
much massive love to all of our tenants
and i hope you never ever feel like some
of these tick tocks
feel but at the same time as landlords i
mean look if you yeah
sometimes dealing with entitled tenants
is also terrible isn't it yeah i know
especially the hm ones when i used to
manage hmos my goodness some of the
things literally all this person's put
cheese on my shelf in the fridge and
it's like why am i having to get
involved in this i feel like everybody
everybody needs to just take a class on
being a decent human being class you
know a lot of landlords need to go on it
but also some tendencies
um so anyway i hope you enjoyed this
video if you did what should they do you
should like and comment and subscribe
there we go there we go we'll see you
guys next time and thanks again for
watching thanks guys bye
[Music]